so what we see in the landing site is a
lot of really great geology you look at
it from orbit and you appreciate that
the things you're looking down on are
really unusual
beneath our feet we have an interesting
jumble of pebbles on a flat terrain we
don't know at this point why we're
seeing just the small pebbles and not
any big boulders like we've seen with
the Viking and the Pathfinder missions
where we landed so that'll be something
that we try to figure out by looking at
the materials and the textures and
structures in in the geology
there's material that was carried down
by water from the rim on Gale Crater and
left it a positive materials and that's
called the alluvial fan so it brought
things to us and that we're carried by
water so again we're interested in past
environments that could have been
suitable for life and so we'll probably
try to check out some of those types of
materials before we head to Mount sharp
for what we think is the ultimate goal
of the mission to look at the lower
layers that are rich in clay minerals
and then to scoot up the base of the
mountain to get to the sulfate minerals
which would presumably record evidence
of a different past environment these
layers the lower parts of Mount sharp
are composed of phyllosilicates and
sulfates which are both hydrated
minerals and so we know from orbit that
we're very likely to have a discovery
that involves some aspect of water on
Egypt Mars this time around I do feel a
sense of responsibility to make sure
that we do everything we can for the
mission to be successful and with that
also comes the responsibility that if
you head in the wrong direction there
will be a price to pay and so you know
for me the planning is incredibly
important and I think this is also
incredibly exciting because it just
looks so good there's just something
about the Gale Crater landing site that
just feels right to me